how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it's been a crazy morning this morning
everybody seems to be freaking out and
panicking about the Hawkeye news last
night we got reports that the upcoming
Hawkeye series on Disney Plus was
delayed indefinitely
and for those who may not know what
indefinitely means it means for an
unknown period of time which could be
forever so the Hawkeye series was
reportedly delayed indefinitely which
could have meant that it's cancelled so
of course everybody was freaking out
everybody was really looking forward to
the Hawkeye series coming to Disney Plus
but have no fear because it seems like
those reports were wrong just a few
minutes ago Julie Alexander from The
Verge tweeted that Disney told her that
these reports were completely inaccurate
her report says news can absolutely
confirm this is untrue Disney contacts
have vehemently denied it calling it
completely inaccurate and she posted
what she was referring to down below a
report from Murphy's multiverse which is
Charles Murphy that says exclusive
Marvel Studios Hawkeye series delayed
indefinitely but Julia Alexander isn't
the only person who have said this other
reporters have stepped up as well saying
that they've heard that this is not true
Caleb Williams who runs a night edge
media has heard that this is not correct
and other journalists as well have
stepped up and said as far as they know
as far as anything that they've heard
it's still on they haven't heard
anything about it being delayed it was
originally reported that the Hawkeye
series was going to be delayed because
of all of the changes that Marvel is
made to their production schedule we've
recently heard that the one division
series got moved up with its release
date which means its production start
date gets moved up as well in fact
they've already begun production and
they're already filming right now but
one thing that happened was Disney's in
Marvel Studios production grid no longer
has the Hawkeye series for a July start
date it's no longer there this is what
led people to think that the Hawkeye
series is delayed or cancelled but again
according to these reports which
apparently come right from Disney
themselves they say that the report of
Hawkeye being delayed and definitely is
inaccurate now it's still reported that
they are eyeing Hailee Steinfeld as the
role of Kate Bishop however nothing has
been confirmed and apparently the search
for Kate Bishop is still on however a
reddit user recently posted to Reddit
saying that he got them
eat her recently and he asked her if she
would placate Bishop and Disney pluses
Hawkeye series and according to this
Reddit user she said no comment with a
laugh and a smile and this user even
posted a picture from the meet-and-greet
as well so it's still very possible that
Hailee Steinfeld could be playing Kate
Bishop in the upcoming Hawkeye series
since it is no longer delayed or
apparently never was delayed so good
news the Hawkeye series as far as we're
concerned is not delayed indefinitely
apparently everything is still on track
and hopefully Marvel Studios and Disney
will put them on the production grid
soon so I know everybody was freaking
out this morning so let me know how
excited you are that the Hawkeye series
is not delayed and would you like Hailee
Steinfeld to play Kate Bishop let me
know what you think in the comments down
below also don't forget to give the
video a like and subscribe but
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU you can check out my Xbox one and
ps4 giveaway in the description down
below and as always thank you all so
much for watching we'll forth
[Music]